here we have a capitol hill watch with
jackie heinrich jackie so much going on
there today the senate moving forward on
covet relief
but without republican support that's
right dana
president biden reportedly told
democrats to move forward
with his 1.9 trillion dollar proposal
not long after sitting down with senate
republicans to try to hash out
a bipartisan deal their 618 billion
proposal was swiftly
rejected democrats yesterday cleared a
procedural hurdle in the senate to move
forward with budget reconciliation
now that's a tool that would allow them
to pass their bigger bill with just a
simple majority
the message to republicans you can join
us but don't try to go to go against us
because we've got the majority and we
are not
backing down
our members who were in the meeting felt
that the president seemed to be more
interested in that
than his staff did or that it seems like
the democratic leadership in the house
and the senate are so here's where i
think we're headed
it looks like the majority is going to
have us vote on the motion to proceed to
the budget
this afternoon they've chosen
a totally partisan path
so moderate democrat senator joe manchin
promised that he will still try to make
this bill as bipartisan as possible
during the budget reconciliation process
and work on some of those points that
republicans find really unpalatable dana
anna